denise we're getting numerous calls and
emails into our newsroom
concerning vaccine distribution in
southern nevada
we always appreciate appreciate hearing
from you and we know you have a lot of
questions we're working to get you those
answers
sally jeremiah now joining us looking
into when you can get a plan
and plan on getting that vaccine the
governor
outlined two new liens frontline workers
and general public
when you get the vaccine depends on
which one you're in the first thing for
everyone to do
is fill out the link for the vaccine
interest form it will notify you
when you are eligible so when would that
be first let's deal with the front line
workers
that includes law enforcement and
teachers down
through food service and hospitality
workers
if you're in that group so far there are
several sites providing the vaccine
such as western high unlv school of
medicine the city of north las vegas
etc southern nevada health district
chief health officer dr fermin again
says the plan is create mega vaccination
centers at cashman center and the las
vegas convention center
our expectation is to be able
to deliver about 40
to 45 000 vaccinations
a week those are expected to open at the
end of this week
if you're not in that group you're in
the general population lane
the plan for the general population is
that they will get their vaccines from
pharmacies
there is an agreement between the state
and
and local pharmacies walgreens cbs
walmart and language meat pharmacies
those
entities will we provide a vaccination
to the seniors ligand says the state
will send those vaccines directly to the
pharmacies
lagaan says he is waiting for more
details on that plan
from the state and he expects them to
release that in a week or two
so if you're in the general population
lane the thing you can do
right now is fill out the form online
that information can be found on our
website
eight newsnow dot com reporting sally
jaramillo